♪ ♪ ♪
- Là, je pense qu'on vient
de voir une paruline bleue.
Une paruline jaune mâle.
- Katherine Collin est
professeure de littérature,
mais lorsqu'elle pénètre
dans ces bois foisonnants,
elle y trouve une poésie
qui s'expriment en chants
et en couleurs.
- C'est l'expérience
de l'émerveillement
devant la nature.
- 200 espèces d'oiseaux
différentes logent ici, un
paradis pour les ornitologues
amateurs déterminés à sauver
ce refuge inusité.
On dit souvent que
le Mont-Royal est le poumon vert
de Montréal. Ce paradis
des ornitologues, c'est
cette tache verte, de la même
superficie que le parc de
la Montagne. Un deuxième
poumon vert potentiel,
quelque 210 hectares de nature
en pleine ville.
Or, l'endroit n'a pas de nom.
Ce n'est pas un parc.
C'est quoi, alors?
Au début 90,
Ville Saint-Laurent rêve
d'un parc industriel à la fine
pointe de la technologie
pour attirer des entreprises
et créer des emplois.
On fonde le techno-parc.
Mais l'affaire ne connait pas
le succès escompté. Si bien
que pas mal de terrains de
ce secteur demeurent en friche
et regorgent de petits marais,
donc d'oiseaux. C'est ce que
les gens appellent le secteur
municipal, 60 hectares.
Près de la moitié des terrains
appartiennent à la Ville.
Tout à côté, on trouve
le secteur fédéral,
avec 150 hectares
non-fragementé de nature.
KATHERINE COLLIN,
Technoparc Oiseaux
- Toutes ces terres-là
appartiennent au fédéral, sous
la responsabilité quand même
d'ADM, donc sous-louées à ADM,
les Aéroports de Montréal,
qui gèrent l'endroit,
qui prennent des décisions.
- Et, selon le plan directeur
d'ADM, ces terres sonts
disponible à des fins
de développement.
- C'est une projet énorme.
- D'ailleurs, Aéroport
de Montréal envisage
de permettre la construction
d'une nouvelle usine dans
un champs où viennent
se reproduire les papillons
monarques, ce qui inquiète
au plus haut point les amants
du parc sans nom.
David Fletcher, de la Coalition
Verte, milite depuis des années
pour préserver le parc fantôme.
Si vous aviez un mot
pour décrire ce qui va
se passer ici, c'est quoi?
DAVID FLETCHER, Coalition Verte
- Oh mon Dieu, c'est criminel!
Exactement, c'est criminel.
- Aéroports de Montréal
nous a écrit que...
Dès 2012, Montréal conçoit
le projet de joindre une vaste
portion des terres fédérales
à celles de la ville.
Mais les négociations
n'ont jamais abouti.
ALAN DESOUSA, maire
de l'arrond. de Saint-Laurent
- Il n'y a pas un autre endroit
où le gouvernement fédéral
est propriétaire des milieux
naturels. Le seul endroit,
c'est ici.
- Alan De Sousa a contacté
son adversaire politique,
mais allié à la cause, Robert
Beaudry, de Projet Montréal,
et la Ville a fait adopter
une résolution pour que
ce projet aboutisse.
ROBERT BEAUDRY, responsable
grands parcs, Ville de Montréal
- Il faut une stratégie globale,
et on veut travailler
avec le fédéral.
- D'ailleurs, en avril dernier,
ADM a créé un espace
de protection. 18 hectares
sur les 150 disponibles.
Elle n'avait pas le choix,
puisqu'une espèce en voie de
disparition, le petit blongios,
nichait autour de ce marais.
- Je pense qu'il faut, à ce
moment-là, avoir l'ambition
de réaliser vraiment un beau
projet, sinon petit à petit,
ce terrain va être développé
par les villes, par l'Aéroport
de Montréal. Mais ultimement,
ma demande est adressée
au propriétaire du terrain.
Ma demande est adressée
au gouvernement fédéral.
- Mais à Ottawa, on nous répond
que c'est ADM qui décide.
Depuis des années, Katherine
Collin arpente le parc sans nom,
voit des routes qui ne mène
nulle part se construire,
des arbres abattus,
des marais asséchés.
Qu'est-ce que ça va faire
dans votre vie si vous perdez
cet endroit-là?
- Oh, ça fait... ça serre le
gosier, quand même, de parler.
La nature, ça nous réconforte,
ça nous donne de l,aide.
Pour moi, ça va être une perte.
Ça va être un deuil, en fait.
Et aussi, une perte énorme
pour Montréal.